[Musik]
Wirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck warnt
jetzt vor Dauerschäden für die deutsche
Wirtschaft nach den Lex einen russischen
Gaspipelines in der Ostsee sagen auch
immer mehr grüne jetzt muss alle ans
alles ans Netz was Deutschland zu bieten
hat auch die Atomkraftwerke Bild sagt
das schon übrigens seit über einem
Jahrzehnt die Sorge vor dem
wirtschaftlichen Absturz sie wird immer
größer es gibt viel zu besprechen heute
Abend bei vielen nach acht mit diesen
Gästen Textilunternehmer Wolfgang Rupp
vermutlich kennen sie ihn sein
weltberühmten Werbespot mit dem Trigema
Affen werden sie definitiv kennen
bildpolitikchef und Mitglied der
Chefredaktion Jan Schäfer sein Thema ist
heute arg ungewohnt für ihn ich bin auch
etwas erstaunt selber aber seine These
ist Respekt für Robert Habeck was ist
damit auf sicherlich bin gespannt
Publizistin Birgit Keller sie fordert
ein Kopftuchverbot für Schulen und
Verwaltung in Deutschland last but not
least der früher FDP Spitzenpolitiker
und ehemalige Wirtschaftsminister im
Kabinett Merkel Rainer Brüderle schön
dass Sie alle da sind mein Thema heute
Abend ist unsere Wirtschaft denn die
blutet aus deutschland droht eine
Abwanderung wichtiger Indus nach
Nordamerika wie das Handelsblatt
berichtet hat und es droht eine
Destabilisierung der Wirtschaft schon
jetzt haben die Unternehmer Angst vor
der Energieversorgung im nächsten Jahr
wie viel nach acht exklusiv er vorher
bereits jetzt eine Gas- und Strom
mangelage und sie trifft unsere
mittelständischen Unternehmen die bei
den großen Anbietern wie Eon keine
Energiemengen mehr für das Jahr 2023
einkaufen können also die rufen da an
und können dann für das Jahr 2023 keine
Energiemenge abschließen während
Haushalte und kleinere Betriebe
automatisch in Ersatzversorgung fallen
während der industrielle Mittelstand
also jetzt bei Stadtwerken und
heimischen Grundversorgern um das Gas
betteln muss werden große Konzerne
individuell beurteilt müssen sich
schlimmstenfalls nur auf Reduzierungen
einstellen das wirtschaftliche Rückgrat
unserer Gesellschaft wird in meinen
Augen so vernichtet wenn dort es nicht
schnell Hilfen und Änderungen gibt wir
haben ja hier heute auch einen
Familienunternehmer am Tisch sitzen die
Nachfolge ist bei Ihnen ja auch schon
geregelt Herr grob und meine Frage ist
natürlich wie sieht es mit ihrer
Stromversorgung im nächsten Jahr aus
beliefern Sie durch die großen
Energieversorger wie E.ON und Co wir
haben ja Kunden Energie Gas und machen
mit zwei Gasturbinen in der Stunde 1600
Kubik machen wir selber eigene eigenen
eigenen Strom und brauchen entsprechend
das Gas 2020 vor zwei Jahren haben wir
etwa 100.000 Euro im Monat Gaskosten
gehabt letztes Jahr 2021 hat sich's
verdoppelt auf 200.000 und jetzt ist so
ein bisschen gesunken aber wo auf dem
Höchststand war hätten wir pro Monat
eine Million Gaskosten gehabt das heißt
12 Millionen jetzt liegen sie bei jetzt
zu so etwa bei 9 Millionen das ist für
uns natürlich nicht machbar ich wir
haben 100% Eigenkapital wir haben stille
Reserven das kann ich auch ein eine
gewisse Zeit durchhalten
selbstverständlich aber ich sag mal das
ist nicht umkalkulierbar in unsere
Produkte weil wir auch ein Glück haben
dass niemand mehr braucht denn wer bei
uns Qualität kauft kann sich leisten und
hat normal den Schrank voll und dann
gefällt ihm die Ware oder die Qualität
und die leistet er sich aber wenn er
knapp bei Kasse wird dann ist aus dann
wird unser Produkt als erstes gespart
auch ich werde mir keinen neuen Anzug
anfertigen lassen weil ich habe genügend
ich mache es nur wenn es mir leisten
kann und so warten wir drauf im Moment
ist die Nachfrage noch sehr gut aber ich
warte darauf bis natürlich der Winter
mal Fuß gefasst hat und die Probleme von
denen wir sprechen die Energiepreise
können sie sich leisten als Trigema wir
können Sie aus den Reserven bezahlen wir
die aber ich kann das nicht Jahre
durchhalten das ist nicht da weil ich
sag mal dann müsste ich die Produkte 20
30 Prozent oder 40 Prozent die Preise
anheben und das ist nicht machbar wie
lange werden sie wenn es jetzt noch so
bleibt durchhalten können also ich habe
ich selbstverständlich meinen
Mitarbeitern die Arbeitsplätze auch in
der pandem in den Pandemie sofort immer
garantiert und da gibt es hergestellt im
ersten Jahr im zweiten Jahr haben wir
online-bar wesentlich stärker haben wir
50 Prozent der das was unsere Geschäfte
nicht verkaufen konnten weil sie
geschlossen waren auf Lager gearbeitet
das finanzieren wir natürlich auch und
sind dann vielleicht später froh dass
wir in das Lager haben so wie wir jetzt
auf froh sind dass wir große
Rohstofflager und gefärbte Stoffe am
Lager haben und im Zweifelsfalle
natürlich unsere Näherin auch
beschäftigen können wenn wir Stoff
weniger färben weil wir im Prinzip
weniger Gas kriegen wir bezahlen im
Moment das Gas aber wenn es weniger wird
und wenn man gar keins mehr bekommt dann
müsste ich die Stoffherstellung das
heißt dann kann ich auch wenn ich kein
Strom mehr machen kann ich brauche ja
ein Jahr etwa um wenn ich sage auf Öl
umstellen dann habe ich eine haben wir
Ölkessel bestellt sofort aber der da hat
ein Jahr Lieferzeit das heißt auch für
die ganze technische Umstellung brauche
ich ein Jahr und so lange mich auf jeden
Fall Gas um die Beschäftigung einmal
zusammenzufassen bevor wir Jan Schäfer
Fragen ist es kritisch für Trigema auch
die Situation wir hatten viele
kritischen Zeiten wir hatten natürlich
es ist kritisch natürlich es ist
unangenehm und ich sag mal natürlich
kostet uns das Geld aber wir haben ja
auch wir dadurch dass wir auch nie ein
Jahr mit Verlusten abgeschlossen haben
haben wir ja Reserven und werden das
auch durchhalten die Mitarbeiter
brauchen keine Angst haben ich
beschäftige sie auch in dieser
schwierigen Zeit weil das ist mein
Problem und nicht das Mitarbeiter das
mitarbeiterproblem die müssen ihre
Leistung bringen und ich muss meine
Leistung bringen indem ich Probleme löse
und wir werden alles tun aber in der
Hoffnung dass irgendwann natürlich die
Politik einsieht dass das so nicht
weitergehen kann aber jetzt kommt
natürlich meine entscheidende Frage wie
kann es überhaupt dazu kommen wie kommt
es dazu dass man 20 Jahre top
zusammenarbeitet sich 100% abhängig
macht von Russland oder von Putin und
von heute auf morgen ist man tot fein da
muss etwas passiert sein was ich sage
das hätten die Politiker spüren müssen
und wir hätten das auf jeden Fall
diplomatisch lösen müssen wenn ich von
meinem Geschäft rüber gehe gegenüber
wohne ich und da würden sich zwei
streiten oder Schlägern und ich würde
nach Hause gehen und dem einen eine
große Axt bringen und dem anderen ein
großes Messer dann würden sie
selbstverständlich sagen der grob hat
nicht mehr alle Tassen im Schrank der
muss doch die auseinander dividieren er
muss die besänftigen und nicht sie mit
sozusagen mit Axt und und wir fragen mal
den politikchef der Bild wieder
Vergleich funktioniert von Herr Group
der Vergleich den auf den würde ich
gerne gleich gerne einmal kurz zu
sprechen kommen ich fand aber spannend
was Sie gesagt haben und hat mir gerade
vorgestellt wenn ich jetzt Robert habe
wäre was gewissermaßen vielleicht für
Belustigung hier am Tisch sorgen kann
dann hätte ich mich zum einen gefreut
über das was Sie gesagt haben nämlich
dass sie die Arbeitsplätze ihrer
Mitarbeiter nicht nur in der
corona-krise aber auch jetzt wieder
gesagt haben aber ich hätte
wahrscheinlich erschrocken auf den
Fernsehschirm oder hier am Tisch auf mit
der Faust auf den Tisch gehauen bei der
Aussage von ihnen dass sie jetzt
möglicherweise bei Gast rausholen aber
sich stattdessen Ölkessel bestellt haben
und dann künftig nicht mehr mit Gas aber
mit Öl ihre Energie betreiben wollen
Ihre Firma betreiben wollen deswegen
auch die ernstgemeinte Frage ist das für
sie die einzige Alternative gewesen oder
gab es nicht die Möglichkeit zu sagen
wir machen das jetzt regenerativ
beispielsweise mit Sonne oder mit Wind
das Problem ist natürlich haben wir
alles diskutiert wir haben ja sofort
eine Firma engagiert die uns alles
durchsucht und sagt was ist machbar und
das erste ist machbar dass wir Öl
besorgen und mit Öl etwas ein Kessel
haben und den Kessel besorgen dass wir
sagen dass wir also wenn man es Gas ganz
gestoppt ist dass wir mit Öl heizen
können dann gibt es natürlich auch
Wasserstoff der das würde aber drei
Jahre dauern bis wir umgestellt haben
und wenn sie sagen Solar ja
Hängen der diesen wir haben Solardächer
aber wir haben alles was machbar war was
vernünftig war wo der Sonneneinstrahlung
entsprechend war auf unseren
firmendächern haben wir mit Solar
ausgestattet aber man hat mir gesagt das
ist ein oder zwei Prozent des
Strombedarfs kann ich damit machen also
sie müssen feststellen sehen dass wir
700 Näherinnen haben 700 Nähmaschinen
Strickmaschinen verbreit die riesen
riesen Heißwasser brauchen und
aufgeheizt werden muss also wir brauchen
1600 kW in der Stunde das sind ein
Beispiel von vielen Unternehmern in
diesem Land ich habe ja auch am Anfang
dieses Beispiel gebracht Herr Brüderle
was mich wirklich schockiert hat das
mittelständische Unternehmen jetzt
gesagt bekommt von Eon also ab 1 Januar
2023 können wir keinen Strom also kein
Gas mehr verkaufen wie schlimm ist denn
die Lage für den Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland die können natürlich zu
anderen Grundversorgern gehen wir gehen
Stadtwerken also die haben jetzt nicht
alle ab 1 Januar keinen Strom mehr kein
Gas mehr wie schwierig ist die Lage für
den Industriestandort Deutschland diese
extrem schwierig das Ergebnis einer
verfielten Energiepolitik jetzt auf die
Füße fällt man natürlich schön bequem
billiges russisches Gas zu nehmen das
lange Zeit ja günstig war übrigens auch
die Begründung des jetzt nostream 2 die
Leitung beschädigt ist da kommt er gar
nichts mehr durch das tun die Versorgung
gar nicht berühren bei uns
die eons können auch nur das verkaufen
was sie haben die Stadtwerke selbst
produzieren ja kein Gas sie kaufen es
bei E.ON oder anderen Händler uniper um
es dann weiterzugeben sie haben ja
gerade eine eigene Produktion dabei ist
nur Verteilung die dort erfolgen und die
Situation hat sich über Nacht verändert
wir dürfen einfach nicht mehr also die
Unternehmer
betrug wenn E.ON gasverkäufer also gar
nicht haben ist sehr betrug die könnte
das nur verkaufen was sie auch verfügbar
haben die Mengen sind nicht da wir haben
es nicht 55% war russisches Gas weg 0
und es war auch eine fahrlässige Politik
ich habe das ja auch eine erlebt auch
zum Teil noch ein abzugsfunktion damals
war der Gedanke weil wir hatten ja die
Kernkraftwerke um 10 Jahr verlängert die
CDU fdp-koalition ich habe daraus fährt
und dann sind Japan 12.000 km entfernt
der Unfall passiert ja das war Taifun
und was alles zusammen ist Erdbeben und
auch in der Anlage etwas und das hat
über Nacht dazu geführt das war eine
denkwürdige Nacht wo Frau Merkel
und auch der bayerische
Ministerpräsident entschieden haben
Seehofer wir gehen zurück auf die zehn
Jahre die rot-grün-beschlossen aber
hätten sie nichts dagegen tun können
damals
gehabt über die Regierung zu entscheiden
wir haben ja ein demokratisches System
wo Mehrheiten sind und Parteiführer
natürlich ein Preh haben ich habe das
nächsten Morgen Deutschlandfunk gehört
als ich das Präsidium gefahren ist und
der Gedanke war dort auch von der grünen
leibhaft begrüß dass das was wegfällt
ich kenne Energie und Kohle wohl auch
möglichst schnell raus durch Gas ersetzt
hat zwar bewusst die Strategie durch
rosige Gas die Lücke die durch
schnelleren Ausstieg aus der Kernenergie
und durch Ausstieg aus der Kohle
entstanden ist auszugleichen und das war
das Risiko mit 55% was reingekommen ist
und ich war immer der Auffassung soll
erst aus der Kohle rausgehen weil die
viel umsehen schädlicher ist als die
Kernenergie die ganze Welt nutzt Energie
sie bauen neue nur in Deutschland war
damals die politische Stimmung die
Entscheidung auch der Dreierkoalition
der Skizze so als Partei der zu rechnen
wir gehen raus und es war gerade zu
Euphorie die haben sie überschlagen
dabei wie schnell bei der ausgehen soll
damit ist diese Gefälle Lage entstanden
jetzt wundern sich dass sie diese
Strategie eingeschlagen haben Russland
an der andere Strategie gefahren ist und
die haben ja diplomatisch versucht die
minskergespräche nochmal die Format
waren ja alles diplomatisch versucht die
gescheitert sind das hat nicht
funktioniert und Russland nicht
geschehen ist ja nicht ein Mann der
alles bestimmt ist auch eine ganze
Herrscher klicke die das Entscheidung
trifft hat sich entschieden womit man
nicht gerechnet hatte Ukraine
einzuvarieren wird man nicht gedacht ist
es noch gibt in unseren Zeiten des einen
dann vom anderen überfallen wird die
einfach einmarschieren und wir wollen es
haben es kann souveränes Land mehr es
gehört Russland wem auch immer aber
jedenfalls nicht eigenständig daraus ist
die Situation entstanden da haben sie
noch die Sanktionen entstand auf
EU-Ebene dass man auch gar keinen Bezug
mehr haben wollte damit ist dann
Schlussstrich da kann man darüber
streiten das war billig war schön aber
die Zeit nehmen einmal festhalten dass
daran jetzt nicht nur Putin Russland
schuldet sondern auch die falsche
deutsche Politik an der Misere die wir
gerade haben die einseitige Ausrichtung
mit 55% von einem lieferantenabhängig zu
sein mit der Gruppe wahrscheinlich nie
machen würde ich würde sagen irgendwie
dass es einfach etwas was nicht geht
mich faszinierende
an dieser ganzen Debatte das irgendwie
alle immer jetzt erzählen wie das alles
so gekommen ist und jetzt sind alle
irgendwie überrascht und niemand wird
haftbar gemacht für gar nichts die die
deutsche Wirtschaft geht gerade den Bach
runter und irgendwie will niemand jetzt
wirklich die Verantwortung dafür
übernehmen auch nicht diejenigen die
über zehn Jahre dafür gesorgt haben dass
wir in diese Abhängigkeit hineingeraten
sind weil es ist natürlich nicht Putin
Schuld und es ist auch nicht die Ukraine
schuld dass wir uns mit 55 Prozent an
Russland gebunden haben sondern das war
ja eine freiwillige Entscheidung die man
aber nicht abgesichert hat und ich frag
mich langsam wirklich was eigentlich in
diesen Ministerien hauptberuflich
gemacht wird so ganz einfach ist es
nicht also es sind schon Leute die was
machen dabei aber es war eine politische
Entscheidung war man glaubte dass
gemeinsam europäische Haus denkt etwa
die Rede vom Putin von Dr Bundestag
zu gewinnen also es war doch eigentlich
schon eine Entscheidung die Bürger
wollten es ja und dann ist ja die
ist Wettbewerb der Parteien um
Zustimmung des Demokratie so
funktioniert sie das andere System aber
wie hat denn reiner Brüderle auf den
Tisch gehauen nachdem er gehört hat wir
steigen aus dem Energie
gebannt und es war ein Tag vor der zwei
Tage vor der Landtagswahl
Baden-Württemberg Rheinland-Pfalz wo
gezielt aus einem Gespräch mit dem
bdi-vorstand berichtet wurde ich hätte
das angeblich gesagt dass er nur vor dem
Wahl Gegenteil ist ich habe gesagt wir
müssen das Anpassen richtig vernünftig
einordnen dabei weil geradezu eine
Hysterie natürlich haben die Grünen
gejubelt den Opposition war und nachdem
die großen Parteien die SPD hatte mit
beschlossen mit dem Grün 10 Jahre deine
Ausstieg dabei auch das gemacht haben
war das allgemeine breiter Konsens ich
war damals eine Mini Minderheit der
anders gedacht hat dabei schon mal alle
volle raus wunderbares genial wir gehen
da möglichst schnell raus hoch riesig
und Technologie die Kernenergie und wir
gehen auf Gas dabei das freundlich und
ist der bessere Weg wenn sie jetzt Frau
Merkel treffen würden mit dem was in der
Zwischenzeit passiert ist was würden Sie
Ihr dann sagen hätten sie mal auf mich
gehört oder würden Sie sagen war alles
Mist damals auch nicht machen sie waren
damals die großen Parteien die Grünen es
war eine Minderheit die dagegen waren
auf diesen Trip das war auch Herr
Röttgen der Umweltminister der wollte
auch wirklich schnell raus war nicht so
Frau Merkel als Physikern ja mit der
Materie bekannt war ja am Anfang mit uns
gemeinsam für die zehn Jahre
Verlängerung das hat wegen Japan dann
abrupt geändert und die Politik geändert
das ist natürlich geändert Frau Merkel
durchaus finde ich dann kann man sie
nicht aus der Verantwortung lassen sie
hat ja damals nicht aus Einsicht als
Physikerin die Atomkraft verlassen
sondern das hat man hat es wirklich aus
wahltaktischen Gründen im Parlament
dafür und eine Demokratie ist es so wenn
Sie mehr hat dafür gibt dann findet
statt es nicht Frau Merkel allein oder
der Oberregierungsrat im Ministerium des
entscheidet sondern klare
parlamentarische Mehrheiten die
abgeschlossen haben das war falsch aber
es gab diese Mehrheit aber da muss man
Demokratie respektieren kann die Zahlen
ich bin schlauer als die parlamentische
Entscheidung
als Unternehmer wen mache ich haftbar
wenn man das Parlament von vor zehn
Jahren oder von vor 15 Jahren kann ich
ja schlecht haftbar machen
ja das ist genau das Problem ich glaube
das ist das alles nur noch GmbH sind
niemand wird Verantwortung übernehmen
sondern alle stehen jetzt irgendwie vor
einer Sache und nicht einmal jetzt in
dieser Situation will man
verantwortungsbewusst handeln oder
wenigstens die Fehler bekennen die
passiert sind und sie auch verändern die
Fehler sind ja öffentlich auch bekannt
dabei natürlich werden sie verändert ist
natürlich sehr schwer wir haben versucht
auf die regenerative Energien zu gehen
sind leider nicht die Leitung gebaut
werden weil die gleichen die für
Ausstieg aus der Kernenergie Atom ist
der Kohle waren denn auch die Leitung
nämlich sehr viel von den Grünen
blockiert haben von Dortmund zum Süden
Wind Energie haben wir mehr in der
Norden Ostsee als in südregion dort sind
die Industrie es muss hunderten
runtergeleitet werden wir haben keine
entsprechende Energieleiter wir können
es gar nicht im Süden runter schaffen um
Baden-Württemberg und Bayern hat die
wenigsten Windkraftanlagen und
Solaranlagen solarhaben so ein bisschen
mehr in Bayern gebaut Baden-Württemberg
ganz wenige im Schwarzwald sehe ich kaum
Windräder die sind an einer Region bei
uns in der Eifel im Pfälzerwald und
sonst zwei sie haben es nicht gemacht
und sie haben sich umgesetzt und es gab
heute die Widerstände in Deutschland
brauchen sie im Schnitt fast 25 Jahre
und Baurecht für ein Stück Straße zu
haben das sind Bürger die dagegen sind
die Einsprüche erheben und das
Blockieren deshalb brauchen wir neue
Regelung wo der schneller geht nicht nur
Frau Keller findet eigentlich das zu
wenig getan wird auch Herr grob hier in
der roten Phase ich wollte nur lernen
ich meine ich finde es ja gut wenn man
sagt Fukushima das hat ja den Bürgern
Angst eingejagt und gewählt Herr
Kretschmer damals
Grün gewählt ich habe immer die CDU
gewählt werden und habe dann aber auch
aber ich wollte nur sagen wenn wir diese
Atomausstieg so schnell besprochen
bestätigt haben dann musste habe ich
mich gefragt wenn Frankreich der bei uns
in Baden-Württemberg 20 Kilometer hinter
der Grenze Atomkraftwerk hat und
Fukushima ja nicht nur jetzt im Umkreis
von fünf Kilometern oder sonst was dann
habe ich mich gefragt das müsste doch
europäisch gemeinsam gelöst werden und
wenn die Franzosen die größte Atomkraft
sind er macht sind immer mehr aufbauen
dann ist es doch falsch wenn wir abbauen
es müsste doch gemeinsam sein und das
und das habe ich im Prinzip immer
gefragt wieso jetzt Logik sie erwartet
einmal zur These von Herr Group von
heute was fordern Sie heute Abend hier
bei 8:15 Uhr
ich will dass wir sagen wir müssen alles
versuchen um diesen Krieg
ich sag mal zurückzufahren und sozusagen
einzustellen und nicht mit Waffen
konstant zu verlängern die wollen sie
das konkret machen das kann ich Ihnen
zeigen
ich bin eben der Meinung dass wir auch
mit Amerika sprechen müssen denn der
Amerikaner Versuch von hinten von hinten
ich sag mal alles zu tun um diesen Krieg
zu verlängern und er macht Geschäfte
damit er hat ja auch im Handelsplatz es
wurde ja hier angeschnitten hat er ja
klar gesagt dass er wird dass er jetzt
ähm das Gas liefern kann und das alles
zu wesentlich teuren Preisen da er will
die Großmacht groß Macht bleiben und die
anderen kleinheiten auch Europa das ist
so also da bin ich ein bisschen zu
einfach ganz ehrlich bezahlt die
Deutschen immer wieder darauf
hingewiesen dass wir uns in eine in eine
einseitige Abhängigkeit zu Russland
begeben und es wurde von deutscher Seite
immer
heraus dass die Amerikaner schlicht
untergreifend Recht hatten mit Warnung
und von deutscher Seite wollte das
niemanden
Amerikaner und was vorzuwerfen das
siegas liefern wollen finde ich jetzt
ehrlich wir sortieren hier einmal
wirtschaftlich ein weil da wurde auch
gerade etwas vermischt das Handelsblatt
hat im Sog von Amerika hier ist die
Headline hat gesagt dass Amerika
profitiert das ist auch so aber sie
haben ja gesagt gehabt dass Amerika
alles steuert diese Aussage
da wollte ich nämlich mal fragen weil
das wird dir als überall getitelt und
das sorgt ja für Unverständnis dass er
grob sagt Amerika würde alle Steuern das
klingt ja sehr nach einer
Verschwörungstheorie das ist nicht ihre
Meinung ihre Meinung ist das Amerika
Amerika ist es nicht unrecht sag ich
dass im Prinzip nachdem er ja mit China
auch die Probleme hat und nicht will
dass China größer wird stärker wird und
selbstverständlich Russland darf nicht
stärker werden und deshalb war es auch
natürlich nicht in im Sinne von Amerika
dass wir diese Geschäfte 20 Jahre
positiv gemacht haben mit Russland weil
damit natürlich Russland
gestärkt wurde wirtschaftlich und auch
Deutschland natürlich und jetzt ist
durch diese ganze Geschichte wird Europa
geschwächt weil es ist ja nicht nur
Deutschland sind ja auch alle Europa
wird geschwächt dadurch wirtschaftlich
geschmeckt und damit ist Amerika
natürlich ganz sicher die große anders
denn schon Obama hat ja gesagt wie er
ist eine Großmacht und Russland sein nur
eine regionale Fakten sind anders auch
die Amerikaner im großen Umfang
russisches Öl gekauft weil es billiger
war als das eigene dabei so ist es nicht
und was die zig Milliarden an Waffen
liefern Ukraine die werden nicht bezahlt
das quasi ein Geschenk der Amerikaner
kriegen die nie Geld dafür und dass wir
LNG jetzt flüssiggaskriegen aus Amerika
ist immer froh aber keins haben es war
froh sind dass wir das kriegen eine
andere unrechtlichkeit ist dahinter in
Deutschland ist Fracking die Methode
dass wir Amerikaner Amerika jetzt
gemacht in Deutschland ist verboten war
nie durchsetzbar Baden-Württemberg
die wir könnten für 30 35 Jahre durch
Fracking in Deutschland so Versorgung
sicherstellen das will man Deutscher
nicht macht keiner das Gas aus Amerika
ist Fracking Gas dort ist es gut für die
Umwelt weil es weit weg ist in
Deutschland ist es Tabu und wird nicht
gemacht das ist die Scheinheiligkeit
dabei aber die Amerikaner haben die
eigentliche Rivalität mit China nicht
mit Russland Russland ist militärisch
eine starke Atommacht zweitstärkste der
Welt aber wirtschaftlich immer noch
klein Helmut Schmidt sagt oberwolter mit
Raketen die eigentliche Konkurrenz zu
Amerika ist China und Russland und die
Aktivitäten Ukraine Schwächen Amerika in
der Rivalität in China dort ist
entscheidend
dass Krieg per se eigentlich immer
schlechtes weil Krieg natürlich
Wohlstand vernichtet eine macht auch wie
Amerika die jetzt ja Milliarde und
Milliarde auch rein buttert um dort in
der Ukraine die Fahne der Freiheit
hochzuhalten die
ist ja nicht weil sie da Lust und Laune
zwar da wird Wohlstand vernichtet so als
wenn man ein Haus kaputt macht und
danach sagt und jetzt bauen wir es
wieder auf mit dem Geld mit dem man das
Haus aufbaut könnte man viele viele
andere Dinge machen Universitäten
bezahlen Forschung bezahlen das Leben
vieler Menschen wahrscheinlich viel
angenehmer machen das heißt was dort
passiert ist eigentlich ein großer
Vernichtungskrieg auch von Geld und ich
glaube sie haben das vollkommen richtig
gesagt das Geld was dort vernichtet wird
das Wortes das könnte man auch nutzen um
viele viele andere Dinge zu machen
beispielsweise die Freiheit auf diesem
Kontinenten aber zu machen wir müssen
auf einen Punkt schon noch mal eingehen
den da sowohl das Handelsblatt
geschrieben hat als auch Herr grub dann
ja auch wiederholt hat es ist ja schon
so dass Amerika gerade als
Industriestandort eher aufgewogen wird
und Deutschland runter geht dann müssen
wir aber auch wissen woran es liegt und
möglicherweise das ist das was man ja
von Unternehmern und sie haben es ja
gerade eben auch ganz toll und plastisch
gesagt immer wieder hört ist natürlich
in Deutschland
Problem dass wir extrem hohe
Produktionskosten gerade beim Thema
Energie haben und wenn man sieht wie
viel Energie beispielsweise
Stahlhersteller brauchen oder auch die
chemische Industrie sie kommen ja auch
aus der Region sag mal weiteren Bereich
richtig schon immer teuer in Deutschland
ja aber wir sehen natürlich jetzt dass
Energie noch mal extrem teuer geworden
ist und es ist auch gar nicht richtig
erkennbar bei der Politik die die
Bundesregierung macht speziell der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister dass man sagen
kann wann wird Energie denn
möglicherweise eigentlich mal wieder
günstiger wenn ich das als Unternehmer
habe und sie sind ja ein Paradebeispiel
dafür auch wie man langfristig plant
Herr grub dann muss man sich als
Unternehmer ja fragen ja bleibe ich denn
einen noch in Deutschland oder mache ich
die nächste Investition für eine Anlage
aus der Tasche und mit Schnitt mit dem
Finger einfach mal so entscheide sondern
die ich lange planen muss in der
Millionen können ja maximal vielleicht
auch mehrere Millionen vielleicht auch
zig Millionen vielleicht sogar eine
Milliarde fließt mache ich die
eigentlich in Deutschland dann mache ich
die da wo ich sicher sein kann
technologieoffenheit ein Stichwort
Energie oder das versucht wird Energie
günstig zu halten und dann in die USA
und bleibt nicht mehr in Deutschland die
machen sie in Amerika nach Amerika
bräuchte des Skills selbst dringend die
Highways die Infrastruktur ist ja
miserablen Zustand ist amerikanische
Bildungssystem die dürfen nicht nur die
Eliteuniversitäten sehen ist der breite
nicht gut die bräuchten das Geld im
eigenen aber sie würden nicht
widersprechen der These dass die
Wirtschaftssanktionen Deutschland mehr
treffen als Amerika und das ist ein Fakt
ist über den man reden muss über alles
reden immer so aber wusste es einordnen
in der richtige logische Entwicklung und
wir haben hausgemachte Probleme die
jetzt akut erkennbar sind wir
Strukturwandel ich Betrieben Deutschland
wir haben viel zu sehr Staatseinfluss
auf die Wirtschaft dabei gehabt wir
haben die Wettbewerbsfähigkeit der
eigenen Land nicht hinreichend gestärkt
wir haben die Steuerschraube überdreht
es gibt kaum ein modernes
Wirtschaftsland ist so hohe steuerliche
Belastung wie Deutschland haben wenn sie
den Leuten alles Geld wegnehmen dann
haben sie nicht die Möglichkeit für
Investition aber gerade nicht das Gefühl
dass die FDP da gerade groß gegen angeht
welche Note würden sie eigentlich gerade
ihrer Partei geben überhaupt keine Noten
und es ist sicherlich ein Punkt für die
auch mal eine Partei immer gestritten
hat lasst den Leuten mir vom Geld übrig
wir haben Staatsanteile und Umverteilung
die nicht effizienter sind zum
Bundeshaushalt an ich habe aber nichts
gegen Sozialpolitik Buch um das Geld hin
wir haben es nicht der Infrastruktur die
Bahn funktioniert hinfahren nicht
empfehlen mal Fahrt mit der Deutschen
Bahn
jeden Freitag sie wollen nicht meine
perfekte haben
anderen Sektoren auch Forschung
Hochschulen vielen Sektoren eben nicht
up to date sind wir haben falsche
Sektoren investiert wir haben ständig
auch im Sozialbereich weiter mütterrente
und sonst was eingeführt und dort wo die
Zukunftsentwicklung ist in der
Grundlagenforschung den Entwicklung
haben wir nicht das Geld investiert aber
wir haben eine schiefe gerade fragen wir
doch mal Frau Kelle und Herr grub
vielleicht sind die offener mit
notengebungen das verstehe ich auch es
ist ja auch ihre parte Frau Kelle welche
Note würden Sie denn der FDP aktuell
geben mangelhaft aber ich würde es der
gesamten Koalition der
Regierungskoalition geben ich weiß gar
nicht ob man das jetzt der FDP alleine
an haften also zu Schulden kommen lassen
muss weil die FDP möglicherweise noch
eine Kraft ist die Vernunft reinbringt
aber ist nicht schafft natürlich auch
jetzt sagen wir mal in diesen in dieser
Kräfte Konstellation durchzudringen was
mich was mich viel mehr beschäftigt ist
und was ich eben vermisse auch in dieser
gesamten Situation ist so etwas wie eine
general general Mobilmachung eigentlich
für Deutschland für den Energiesektor
wir haben so viele hat es ja schon hat
es ja angesprochen wir haben ja durchaus
Kapazitäten in Deutschland für
energiegewendung die wir schlicht
untergreifend aus ideologischen Gründen
nicht anfassen das heißt wir sehen
gerade zu wie wie eine Destabilisierung
der gesamten Wirtschaft passiert mit
einer Kettenreaktion ja Unternehmen die
nicht mehr produzieren müssen irgendwann
Leute entlassen wandern vielleicht ab
das heißt wir haben sozusagen eine kein
überhaupt keine Perspektive Deutschland
von Leuten die abwandern wollen ich höre
seit Jahren Menschen von Menschen die
aus Deutschland auswandern wollen und es
werden immer mehr und das wird das sind
nicht die Leute die in den
Sozialsystemen sind sondern das sind
eigentlich die Leistungsträger die sich
fragen ob sie eine Zukunft haben in
diesem Land und da fehlt mir wirklich
der Wille also auch der sichtbare Wille
im Moment in der in der Ampelkoalition
dass man sagt wir brauchen jetzt
wirklich eine stabile general
Mobilmachung für Energie in Deutschland
und da müssen wir jetzt alle über
unseren Schatten springen und da geht es
gar nicht um Universitäten Straßen oder
die Deutsche Bahn da können wir alle
jetzt mal ein paar Monate darauf
verzichten aber wenn wir unsere Arbeit
doch doch ich glaube dass das so
angesichts dessen was worauf wir gerade
zusteuern das Deutsche Bahn verzichten
ja nein ich meine die Investitionen
darin die ja das ist im Prinzip eine
luxusdebatte weil wir laufen auf ein
Problem zu dass viel gravierender ist
und was auf die nächsten Jahrzehnte
nicht mehr erlaubt dass wir Positionen
machen in Schulen oder in Bildung oder
Universitäten sondern es geht langsam an
die Substanz und da wird würde ich mir
wünschen einfach auch ein
Wirtschaftsministerium eine Regierung
die wirklich alle Kräfte mobilisiert und
das bedeutet dass man nicht irgendwie
Monate braucht um zu entscheiden dass
man von drei Atomkraftwerken zwei jetzt
vielleicht doch weiter laufen lässt dass
wir Fregatten woanders kaufen haben nein
aber all diese Dinge ich meine warum
diskutieren wir nicht mal wirklich
konkret einen Plan für Deutschland wie
wir energiemäßig autark werden eine der
erlaubt dass wir vielleicht irgendwann
mal auf billigeren Strom kommen
abholen weil ich glaube das würde die
Sendung sprengen Frau Kelle gibt
mangelhaft welche Note geben sie denn
sie sind doch ein Mann der Klartext
kann ich verstehen aber in der heutigen
Situation aber ich muss jetzt mal sagen
Demokratie ist natürlich die
schwierigste Regierungsform denn ich sag
mal gerade wenn wir jetzt sagen wir
haben drei Parteien und hier und wenn
ich dann die Opposition höre das ist ja
jetzt im Moment die CDU und der hat der
sagt 1&1 ist zwei dann sagt der andere
garantiert das ist drei verstehen sie da
wird nur Kontra gegeben und nicht auch
mal zugestimmt ich würde natürlich in
einer Regierung auch mal als Opposition
sofort sagen das ist top das würde ich
so machen und die wir müssen das
Ausbauen und so weiter aber wenn wir
schon dann recht unser Rechtssystem so
ist dass wenn wir Windräder ich sag mal
wenn wir das alles veranlassen wenn wir
Jahre brauchen bis die genehmigt sind
und gemacht sind da muss man natürlich
auch etwas trinken aber das ist hinter
Demokratie gesagt ihr Unternehmen könnte
jedenfalls mit Windrädern und
Solardächer nicht funktionieren also
insofern ist es vielleicht grundsätzlich
der falsche Ansatz nein ich sag mal das
ist jetzt nur ein Beispiel dass wir
sagen wir können ja überall Solar Dächer
machen wo sie wo sie machbar sind nur
für uns wäre das mit eigenen
solartechniken
mitgebracht und die impliziert auch eine
Lösung ja muss alles aktivieren was wir
an Energieleistung bringen können
einiges macht die Region muss auch ein
bisschen okay sein der sie jetzt die
flüssige die schwimmenden Terminals
angeschafft hat oder gemietet hat
immerhin zwei bis Ende des Jahres indem
wir den Flüssiggas ins Netz
hineinbringen kann ist ein Fortschritt
ich würde in der Tat da bin ich mit der
Gruppe auch einig wie wir es nach der
Wiedervereinigung gemacht haben die
Planungsverfahren oft Zeit verkürzen nur
eine widerspruchsebene nicht über
x-ebene hinein Widerspruchsmöglichkeiten
zu geben das muss aber den durchhalten
und es machen und dann muss man auch
bereit sein entsprechende Veränderung zu
akzeptieren wir können das schon mal
ganz kurzfristig geht's nicht gelle da
muss man schon ein bisschen Zeit haben
die nächsten zwei Jahren sind die
kritischen dieser Winter und 23 das sind
die beiden kritischen da müssen uns
behelfen mit Flüssiggas übrigens Amerika
immer gut funktioniert Frankreich
funktioniert nicht die Hälfte der
Kernkraftwerke sind nicht nutzbar
derzeit sind auch eine schlichtere
Technik einfach als Deutschland ja weil
sie nicht kühlen können und B was ich
gemacht trotzdem sind nicht
funktionieren dabei und so waren viel
besser wir sind es ist halt mehr als
Entscheidung ich war andere Auffassung
länger genutzt sind wir draußen das kann
man nicht revidieren mehr das müssen und
den Gegebenheiten möglichst das neu
justieren und man muss auch neue prüfen
ob wir nicht Fracking im Land machen und
ich würde alle drei Kernkraftwerke die
noch haben nutzen ist natürlich
Durchsicht die Wahl Taktik von ein
Habicht des Niedersachsen wurde Liga
Landesverband der grün ist das war der
Landtagswahl 9 Oktober das nicht macht
um da möglichst viel Stimmen zu kriegen
Illusion zu wecken ist Politik aber
schlechte Politik
wir haben heute eine Entscheidung von
dann habe ich muss jetzt einmal dieses
wunderbare Mikrofon benutzen weil
offenbar mein anderes Mikrofon kaputt
ist deswegen nicht wundern warum ich
hier so ein Eis in der Hand halte aber
ich glaube das was heute passiert ist
das würde ein bisschen dem widersprechen
was sie gerade gesagt haben mein Bruder
denn die kehrt werdet ihr habe heute
vollzogen hat Richtung AK Wände so
nennen wir das jetzt mal also zwei
mindestens zwei Kernkraftwerken zu
erlauben das reicht es eine andere Frage
bis ins Frühjahr 2023 im Netz zu bleiben
die Haut den seinen Parteifreundin
Niedersachsen so voll ins Kontor das
Shepherd bis hier nach Berlin die Plakat
hier mit bye bye AKW und der eigene
Wirtschaftsminister und bisherige
parteikode Gehirn sagt zwei Wochen vor
der Landtagswahl bei AKW machen wir
nicht wir lassen die Dinger länger am
Netz also da sheparts ganz gewaltig und
ich bin gespannt der hat ja zwei
Herausforderungen eigentlich einmal die
den die Wahl am 9 Oktober
und dann noch den Bundesparteitag heißt
der Bundes Delegiertenversammlung eine
Woche später der einzige der sich freut
wissen Sie wer das ist das ist hadex
Schwager der
FDP-Spitzenkandidat Stephan Bürkner der
wird heute Abend sicherlich eine Flasche
Shampoos aufmachen und einen großen
Unterschied wenn man regiert das habe
ich auch alles erlebt da muss man
Entscheidungen treffen als Opposition
kann so schön erklärt programmieren und
Sprüche für Landschaft tragen hast du
keine Verantwortung der Umsetzung dabei
jetzt zum Amt drin
fühlen und die beiden südlichen
Atomkraftwerke weit weg von
Niedersachsen da tut er sich vielleicht
außerdem will das nur bis April
verlängern ich würde sie 40 Jahre
verlängern aber er muss man muss dem
habe ich aber das auch sehr positiv
anrechnen dass er den Mut hat auch
sozusagen das jetzt zu verlängern was
für die für die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland natürlich ganz wichtig ist
dass wir das weiter das kommt und da
muss ich sagen das wäre ein großer
Pluspunkt wie ist das für Habig dass er
den Mut hat gegen die Türkei Interessen
das als eben als Wirtschaftsminister
durchzusetzen und deshalb kriegt er
dafür sicherlich mehr Pluspunkte als er
Negativpunkt
einmal ich möchte ein bisschen Wasser in
den Wein schütten weil ganz ehrlich Herr
Habeck hat jetzt quasi sagen wir mal
zwei von drei entschieden weiterlaufen
zu lassen eine Entscheidung die seit
Monaten überfällig ist ja wo man sagt
jeder der auch nur halbwegs Verstand hat
weil wusste das muss weiterlaufen ich
glaube dass Herr Haarwerk etwas ganz
anderes taktisch gerade tut dass er
nämlich versucht den letzten Rest
Glaubwürdigkeit zu retten denen
vielleicht irgendwie in seiner
politischen Laufbahn noch retten möchte
denn spätestens nach der Wahl hätte er
sowieso einknicken müssen aber der
Glaube ich ja schlecht auf ein Parteitag
stellen und sagen wir sind dagegen und
wir schade die glaubwürdigkeiten
sozusagen
innerhalb seiner Partei setzt ja jetzt
schon auf Spiel es ist ja nicht so als
wäre die absolute Mehrheit der Grünen
würden die mir zujubeln na er kann ja
sozusagen nur eine Entscheidung als
Wirtschaftsminister treffen er kann ja
nicht sozusagen für seine Partei
entscheiden mit Sicherheit zusammen
machen wir haben doch langsam gelernt
dass das Politiker nicht trennen Partei
und Land schöner und hat das entschieden
als grüner Politiker
zu retten weil er nämlich
auch die sein müsste der nach dem
Parteitag
sich nehmen sondern auch der gesamten
Öffentlichkeit in Deutschland zu
erklären dass das was auf ein Parteitag
noch verkündet hat eine Woche später
nicht mehr gilt und damit wäre ja seine
eigene Glaubwürdigkeit als
Wirtschaftsminister völlig hinüber ja
Stromproduktion die der diskutiert
werden Joschka Fischer hat das gleiche
Gitarren die Grünen waren gegründet als
Anti atomkraftbewegung und
Friedensbewegung Joschka Fischer hat den
ersten auslandsansatz deutscher
Streitkräfte damals weil weitaus holen
mit Auschwitz begründet
Balkan möglich gemacht da hat er noch
den roten pfadbeutel da die Fresse
bekommen also
das ist schon Architekt ist aber was
bleibt jetzt über von den Grünen ich
meine die Grünen wurden gewählt für
Krieg ohne Waffen die Grünen wurden
gewählt für keine Verlängerung der
Atomkraftwerke also was bleibt langsam
noch von der Partei über wir werden
natürlich für 100 Aspekte gewählt sie
werden nicht nur für zwei Punkte gewählt
deshalb haben die alle die die Programme
die kein Mensch liest aber sie hat sie
dabei den Grünen ist natürlich dass
anti-akkw gehen so stark wie kein
anderer lieber mit dem keine
Steuererhöhung oder Steuersenkung gehen
bei der
fdp-kraft umstritten ich war dafür
genau
also ich wollte noch mal sagen das hat
die akw-wahl den Grünen ist so stark wie
bei Ihnen das steuersenkungs gehen also
zumindest in der FDP von daher ist das
glaube ich was Robert habe gemacht dann
schon es ist möglich der Kurs richtig
verdient Mut verdient Respekt bekommen
zu dem Thema sicherlich gleich noch
einmal aber es ist mehr glaube ich als
ein wahltaktisches Manöver es ist in dem
Fall ein eine Entscheidung pro
Deutschland und gegen die eigene Mann
ganz kurz Unterbrechung und dann kommen
wir zu Robert Habeck zurück bis gleich
wir sind zurück und geben direkt zur
These von politik-chef Jan Schäfer ja
ich muss heute sagen Respekt Robert
Habeck die Entscheidung ist erst wenige
Stunden alt Robert habe ich gerade
angekündigt dass er nach jetzigem Stand
zwei der drei Atommeiler in Deutschland
über den Jahreswechsel hinauf hinaus am
Netz lassen wir das überraschen denn
Robert Habeck steht in seiner Partei
massiv unter Druck nicht nur
Außenministerin Annalena baerbock auch
der alt-linke und Grünen Strippenzieher
Jürgen Trittin hat in den letzten Wochen
und Monaten immer wieder gesagt
Laufzeitverlängerung nicht mit uns von
daher hat Robert Habeck etwas gemacht
wir haben das gerade auch schon
diskutiert vor einer wichtigen
Landtagswahl die Katze aus dem Sack zu
lassen und zwar die die sehr unangenehm
ist für ihn und vor allem für seine
Partei das heißt für ihn steht der
Härtetest eigentlich wirklich noch bevor
es wird jetzt hart für ihn in der
eigenen Partei und er hat natürlich zu
Recht Begehrlichkeiten geweckt denn nur
zwei Meiler bis Frühjahr 20 laufen zu
lassen das haben wir gerade auch schon
diskutiert das reicht natürlich für die
viertgrößte Industrienation Deutschland
überhaupt nicht aus alle drei Meiler
müssen weiter laufen und am besten
müssen zweimal davon denen die
stillgelegt sind zurück ans Netz Robert
Habeck hat jetzt die Chance zum
endgültigen Polit alphatiert zu werden
oder zum endgültigen Absteiger je
nachdem wie das Ganze ausgeht Frau Kelle
Politik Alphatier Robert Habeck sonst
war ja immerhin
ich glaube dass Herr Habeck gerade
tatsächlich ein realitätsschub hat aber
in meinen Augen hat er den einfach spät
deswegen tue ich mich ein bisschen
schwer mit der Beweihräucherung obwohl
ich durchaus sehen kann dass es für ihn
nicht einfach werden wird auf den
Parteitag dass seinen eigenen Leuten zu
erklären gleichzeitig muss man sehen
dass Herr Habeck in seinen Umfragewerten
gerade massiv in den Keller eingebrochen
ist und die werden wieder nach oben
gehen dadurch dass er diese Entscheidung
getroffen hat zwar nicht von seinen
eigenen Partei draußen sondern von von
von
aus allen anderen Lagern und aus der
Wirtschaft wird man aufatmen dass dieser
Mann langsam vernünftig wird aber ich
tue mich tatsächlich schwer hier
sozusagen eine ein Lob auszusprechen
weil es einfach nur eine überfällige
Entscheidung ist wo man sich wo ich mich
eher Frage warum kommt sie so spät warum
ist jemand der so im in dieser
Verantwortung steht erst jetzt bereit
etwas zu tun was so glasklar jeder
wusste dass es gar nicht anders geht und
weil die per und wo ist die Perspektive
weiter weil zwei von drei
Atomkraftwerken ist ein Tropfen auf den
heißen Stein und es ist immer noch kein
Konzept also wenn dann würde ich an
seiner Stelle wenn ich sein Stratege
wäre wenn er schon Streit anfängt in
seiner Partei dann würde ich einen
großen Plan aufstellen und sagen wenn
schon Streit dann sollte es sich lohnen
und dann sollte er nicht nur sagen wir
lassen zwei weiter laufen sondern wir
müssen jetzt erst einmal welche bauen um
uns später überhaupt irgendwann mal
leisten zu aus den fossilen Brennstoffen
auszusteigen dass wir entfernen von von
einem Heiligenschein für Robert Habeck
da stimme ich Ihnen voll und ganz zu
dafür ist es viel zu früh ich glaube man
muss aber an dem heutigen Tag einmal
erkennen das Robert Habeck einen Schritt
gemacht hat in die richtige Richtung und
das ist glaube ich anerkennenswert und
ich glaube so muss man das auch deuten
es wäre falsch zumindest aus meiner
Sicht wenn man eigentlich egal was der
Wirtschaftsminister macht immer sagt
alles falsch alles falsch man muss dann
glaube ich auch mal sehen dass er in dem
Fall ja auf Druck reagiert hat das ist
sicherlich keine Herzensangelegenheit
gewesen das bereitet ihm sicherlich
physische Schmerzen ganz klar aber eine
Tür glaube ich ist jetzt offen uns
aufgestoßen und auch der Punkt den sie
gemacht haben zu sagen müssen wir
vielleicht sogar über den Bau neuer
Kernkraftwerke nachdenken ja warum denn
eigentlich nicht machen ja viele
Nachbarländer um uns herum auch die
Tschechen beispielsweise frisch mit
einer Ankündigung eine Reaktor aus
Kanada oder kanadischer Bauart künftig
zu bauen also das ist sicherlich eine
Debatte die wir führen müssen ganz klar
aber überhaupt erstmal zu sagen okay wir
verlängern und erstmal nur zwei und dann
drei Monate ist schon mal an erster
Schritt und meine Hoffnung natürlich
ganz klar ist dass dem jetzt viele viele
weitere folgen dass der Druck so groß
wird und dass dieses Land diese
viertgrößte Industrienation der Welt
eine Perspektive bekommt für
die nächsten Jahre den Stromhunger den
dramatisch wachsenden Strom Hunger den
wir haben zu stillen und zwar zu Preisen
die einigermaßen bezahlbar sind für uns
und für die Unternehmer Herr grob wie
geht es ihnen eigentlich wenn ich die
Frage stellen darf als Unternehmer mit
einem Wirtschaftsminister der noch nie
in der Wirtschaft tätig war und damit
muss ich leben wir sind in einer
Demokratie und ich habe die Grünen nicht
gewählt aber wie geht es Ihnen
persönlich
akzeptiere ich akzeptiere natürlich alle
die da sind und da warte das sie
entscheiden und ich sage jetzt mal das
was sie auch gesagt haben das ist der
erste Schritt in die richtige Richtung
und der wird jetzt dann erkennen müssen
dass er weitergehen muss und ich sag mal
was mich natürlich in der einer in der
Politik immer wo ich bewundere ich sag
mal das nicht klare Entscheidungen
getroffen werden sonst schrittweise oft
wird werden Dinge gemacht so wie jetzt
auch und das sollte natürlich die
Atomkraft vor allem wenn was ich ja
vorhin schon gesagt habe wenn Frankreich
sozusagen alles aufbaut und und unser
Nachbar ist und man dann trotzdem hier
aussteigt das ist schon der urfehler
gewesen damals dass man gesagt hat
entweder steigen wir europaweit aus oder
ja das wird schwierig ist und wenn die
Kernkraft sicher ist ich sag mal dass es
immer einen Unfall geben kann das wird
immer geben dass dann muss ich vieles
andere auch abstellen ich sage mal das
war sicher damals eine sehr schnelle und
nicht ganz 100% richtige Entscheidung
die wird sollte jetzt korrigiert werden
wenn wir keine Alternative haben
mindestens dass wir sagen okay das ist
sicherer als das andere und dann müssen
wir dran arbeiten und das wäre eine
Lösung und habe gehört nicht drumherum
kommen so wie sie es gesagt haben
sozusagen nach dem ersten kleinen
Schritt den nächsten kleinen bis zu
einem größeren Schritt dann von
nachzuvollziehen aber das Europa von dem
die sprechen gibt es nicht Europa
handelt eben nicht geschlossen gemeinsam
wir haben keine europäische Armee im
Prinzip wir haben eine Währungsunion
ohne politische Union dabei es war
früher klare Position noch von Kohl erst
Währungsunion wenn man eine politische
Union haben was ja auch Sinn macht ist
sie Instrumentarien da sind wir sehen
jetzt auch bei dem Euro das vieles nicht
funktioniert wir haben natürlich
unheimlich viel Liquidität geschaffen
die uns jetzt auf die Füße fällt und sie
aktiv wird dabei wir haben nicht die
gleiche Stabilität wie die D-Mark die
EZB ist nicht einer Bundesbank das sind
andere Mechanismen sie hat viel Lira
Effekte in ihrer Struktur drin das muss
einfach sehen man darf sich da kein
Wunschdenken machen und weil Frankreich
Atomenergie anders reingings Deutschland
noch lange nicht durch was wir jetzt
machen müssen ist Deutschland zum
modernisieren sie haben es vorhin ganz
schön formuliert Frau Keller dass wir
eine Art Mobilisierung generalmobil
fällt man nicht so militärisch ich habe
es nicht so mit militärisch
Auseinandersetzung sondern wir müssen
die Aktivitäten freisetzen wir haben zu
viel Engpässe zu komplizierte Verfahren
zu lange Vorläufe vernehmungsverfahren
es kann doch nicht sein deswegen
Baugenehmigung ja oder zwei brauchen
deswegen Stempel drauf drücken muss
Umkehr machen wenn vier Wochen nicht
entschieden ist gilt als gefährlich wir
haben ja nicht nur das Energieproblem
wir haben ja auch ein militärproblem
sagen definitiv viele wenn die Berichte
stimmen die ich über sie gelesen habe
waren sie schon 1997 gegen die
Wehrpflicht ich war für ein Berufsarmee
weil die moderne Technik Anrufe Daten
abfordert ja andere Soldaten erfordert
als in einer Länge um was wo sie viele
gewehrträger brauchen sind Hightech
Armeen heute wenn sie sehen was da
produziert werden alle großen westlichen
Demokratien haben Berufsarmee die
Amerikaner die schneller die Franzosen
Italiener ich kenne keiner mehr außer
den Russen das funktioniert nicht die so
andere Strukturen haben das macht schon
Sinn dass man das entsprechend
umstrukturiert war es aber der Fehler
war dass wir die Bundeswehr als
Steinbruch für Finanzierung missbraucht
hat wir hatten früheren Zeiten
zweieinhalb Tausend Leopard Panzer wäre
heute 238 wir werden gar nicht in der
Lage und selbst zu verteidigen ohne
Amerikaner kann sich Europa in
Deutschland nicht verteidigen irgendwann
habt ihr aber gerade die Schnauze voll
von diesem komplizierten Europa
kommunizierten deutschen genau oder
Bedenken und schwerliche Diskussion
haben da muss Europa in Deutschland auch
in der Lage sein ein Stück
Selbstverteidigung selbst zu
bewerkstelligen der Trump hat durchaus
recht gehabt wir haben versprochen zwei
Prozent auszugeben für
Verteidigungsmaßnahmen wir haben es
nicht erfüllt wir haben es nicht gemacht
immer drumherum geredet und die haben
Munition für zwei Tage nato-vorschrift
ist mindestens 30 Tage wir haben unsere
eingegangene internation Verpflichtung
nicht erfüllt die Amerikaner Rügen uns
zu Recht und wir haben ja auch aktuell
noch andere außenpolitische Probleme und
da haben sie heute ein Thema mitgebracht
Frau Kelle ja abseits von
energiepolitischen Fragen braut sich in
Deutschland in meinen Augen gerade auch
durch die Migration in den vergangenen
Jahren ein Thema zusammen wir sehen im
Iran den Freiheitskampf der Frauen die
dafür kämpfen dass sie das erste Mal in
ihrem Leben das Kopftuch ablegen können
ohne dafür verhaftet und im Gefängnis zu
landen wir sehen die Unruhen und jetzt
wird natürlich auch in Deutschland
diskutiert es wird aber ein Schlaglicht
auf die Debatte die wir in Deutschland
bislang nicht geführt haben nämlich die
Frage warum eigentlich in Deutschland
zunehmend Mädchen und Frauen mit
Kopftuch herumlaufen und wann wir
endlich anfangen uns mit diesen
hausgemachten Problemen zu befassen ich
denke es ist an der Zeit dass wir das
was wir dem Ausland immer erklären und
das was wir unter feministischer
Außenpolitik erklären dass wir das auch
im Inland anwenden und dass wir ein
Kopftuchverbot jetzt brauchen auch für
die Schul in Deutschland und für die
Verwaltung um dieses politische Symbol
dass man zunehmend sieht und er immer
jüngeren Frauen und jüngeren Mädchen man
sieht teilweise Grundschulmädchen
inzwischen mit Kopftüchern dass wir hier
in unserem Land genauso für die Freiheit
und für die Selbstbestimmungsrecht der
Frau kämpfen müssen auch gegen einen
zugewanderten Islam wie wir bereit wären
das Wort zu ergreifen für die Frauen im
Iran
Herr grub wie empfinden Sie es das sind
Schulen in der Verwaltung Kopftuch
getragen werden darf gut für mich ist
das noch nie nachvollziehbar gewesen
dass ich sage ich gebe einem Asyl und
lass ihn hier reinkommen und dann muss
ich mich an ihn nach seinen Vorschriften
richten wenn einer zu mir zu Gast kommt
hat er sich nach meinen Vorschriften zu
richten ansonsten ist noch nicht mein
Gast und das war für mich immer
uniskutabel dass wir sagen der Kopftuch
und da ist das und da wollen wir
Moscheen und das und so weiter ich hätte
das von Anfang an hätte ich das verlangt
wenn einer beim bei uns wohnen will und
hier
einwandern will dann muss er sich auch
an unsere Gewohnheiten richten so wie
ich mich selbstverständlich auch im
Ausland danach richte wie die das wollen
und und wie wir das haben ob das in
Japan ist oder ob das in Amerika ist und
ich richte mich auch in der Schweiz
danach dass man wesentlich langsamer
fahren darf als in Deutschland dürfte
man bei Trigema mit Kopftuch Arbeiten
der Gruppe ich das ist dort wird mit
Kopftuch gearbeitet ja aber es wird
vorgeschrieben dass es nicht störend
nicht stört und so weiter und Verschlag
ganz verschleiert gibt es nicht das ist
untersagt aber es ist für uns ja
schwierig wenn es allgemein sozusagen
gestartet ist dass ich dann sage bei mir
im Betrieb gestatte ich das nicht weil
wir haben 2025 Nationalitäten und das
sind eben auch solche dabei und ich sag
mal und das was der Staat zulässt dann
selbst zu verbieten das wäre für uns
schwierig aber ich hätte es begrüßt wenn
von vornherein gesagt hätte so muss es
hier ablaufen denn ich persönlich finde
das auch nicht in Ordnung und ich sag
mal ich trage ja auch wenn ich im
Ausland bin ich sag mal als ich ein
Saudi-Arabien zum ersten Mal war mit
meiner frisch eingehärteten Frau dann
durfte sie nicht ins Schwimmbad weil das
nur für Männer reserviert war das hat
sie selbstverständlich akzeptiert sie
musste Kopftuch tragen weil das
selbstverständlich so war wir haben uns
dort nichts dabei gedacht wir haben uns
an das gehalten was das Land
vorgeschrieben hat weil wir das schätzen
und weil wir die Leute auch dann gesagt
haben wenn die das so wollen dann machen
wir die Frage die ich mir stelle ist
warum man überhaupt in solche Länder
fährt oder sich dort anpasst also ich
würde die ich würde dir ich würde die
moralische Frage noch viel größer
aufmachen weil wir sind ja ganz
großartig im moralisieren auch in
Deutschland das heißt wenn wir von
Schurken kein Gas kaufen warum finden
Sie noch nie außerhalb in der Moschee
beispielsweise
ich muss ja nicht zwingend irgendwo
reingehen wo man mich wo man mich zwingt
ein Kopftuch zu tragen sondern ich finde
da fängt genau die Prinzipien sollten
die Prinzipien anfangen und wenn ich
dann jetzt sehe jetzt beklagen die
Grünen hier und jetzt hören wir Grüne
stimmen ja wir müssen jetzt das Kopftuch
im Iran und wir sind stehen mit
Solidarität ich erinnere mich noch gut
an die Fotos von Claudia Roth wie sie
mit Kopftuch im Iran stand auf ihren
Besuchen das heißt fühlt sich teilweise
freiwillig in Kopftücher wir haben wir
erleben gerade auch in bei den bei den
linken Parteien eine unglaublich absurde
Debatte man kämpft hier in Deutschland
von feministischer Seite dafür auch für
das Recht auf Kopftuch tragen während
auf der anderen Seite der Welt die die
Frauen die feministischen Frauen fragen
wo seid ihr im Westen um uns zu
unterstützen weil für uns ist das
Kopftuch das Symbol der Unterdrückung
das heißt wir wir führen hier Luxus
Debatten die völlig abwegig sind und
reden das Kopftuch schön und das kann
man nun sagen wir machen
ich glaube das luxusdebatte viele Frauen
in Deutschland auch die es vielleicht
freiwillig sich dazu entscheiden und das
zum Beispiel bei der Arbeit bei Trigema
tragen möchten wenn Sie das als
luxusdebatte beschreiben glaube ich
würden sie auch manche Frauen einfach
beleidigen und verletzen ich würde sagen
ich würde gerne zu einem
gesellschaftlichen Zustand kommen ich
würde ihnen übrigens recht geben in der
Frage bei erwachsenen Frauen da muss man
durchaus unterscheiden es gibt die
Frauen die erwachsenen Frauen die
tatsächlich das Kopftuch gerne tragen
wollen ich möchte dass sicherstellen die
Freiwilligkeit auch in Deutschland und
mit Verlaub ich sehe selbst im
Schwimmbad Kinder Mädchen die quasi noch
völlig noch nicht einmal am Ansatz der
Pubertät sind die inzwischen quasi mit
ganzkörperkleidung in deutschen
Freibädern auftauchen ich sehe Mädchen
die komplett verschleiert sind bis auf
das Gesicht die noch schon vor der
Pubertät bei uns auch im ländlichen Raum
sieht man diese Mädchen ich zweifle
einfach an dass hier eine Freiwilligkeit
vorausgesetzt werden kann und ich möchte
gerne dass wir als freiheitliche
Demokratie sicherstellen vehement
dass auch diese Mädchen frei groß werden
und sich freiwillig dafür entscheiden
können und diese Freiwilligkeit ist
nicht gegeben hier würde ich gerne
einmal Herrn Brüderle fragen wie sie auf
die Debatte blicken ich hatte den Ansatz
für falsch ich bin gegen Zwang aber eine
Frau freiwillig im Kopftuch tragen will
kann sie das Judy keine Kipper tragen in
Deutschland ist ein gutes Recht
katholische Schwester kann auch eine
entsprechende kopfkleidung betragen ich
habe einen wahlkämpf dasselbe fdp-kappe
getragen so mein gutes Recht und wir
lösen die Probleme im Iran nicht wenn
man hier
Mechanismen einführen das eine Frau die
ist vielleicht freiwillig will die hat
ein anderes Empfinden als unseres dabei
ein Soles Kopftuch trägt dann soll sie
es machen mich stört das nicht ich finde
gegen ein Zwang keiner in Deutschland
gezogen Kopftuch zu tragen ist keiner
gezwungene Kipper zu tragen das ist
alles freiwillig Entscheidung ist auch
keine gezwungene Nonnentracht durch die
Gegend zu tragen ist alles hier
freiwillig Entscheidung und wir helfen
den Problemen im Iran 0 also wir solche
Mechanismen
sagen konnte
im Schwimmbad freiwillig machen wir
gleich noch eine Sittenpolizei in
Deutschland schwimmen Wildnis soll er
das machen ich bin dagegen
Zwangsmechanismen einzuführen bei uns
dann sehen wir auf der gleichen Stufe
wie die anderen wenn der freie
Entscheidung so ist okay
bei der Debatte um den Iran vor allem
dass es Politiker gibt ja auch in
Spitzenämtern in absoluten Spitzenämtern
diesem Land die eigentlich dem
mulla-regime immer wieder auch sehr
devot gegenüber aufgetreten sind
gratuliert haben wenn es irgendwas
angeblich zu gratulieren gab da hat eine
Demokratie was das angeht wirklich
versagt hat sich zu einem ja Duckmäuser
gegenüber einem totalitären Regime
gemacht das ist eigentlich der
Grundschule den ich anpranger in dem
Fall ist es Steinmeier der einfach
gratuliert zu einem Jahrestag eines
totalitären Regimes wie wir im Iran
sehen dass Frauen unterdrückt und zwar
auf brutalste Art und Weise und das ist
das was ich jetzt in dieser kurzen Zeit
gerne sehr sehr viele für heute der
Schlusswort wir sind am Ende der Sendung
angekommen ich hoffe es hat ihnen viel
Spaß gemacht wie mir und wir sehen uns
morgen abend wieder tschüss schönen
Abend noch
[Musik]